[Music]
and vaginas for days news do you
remember friends
Ross Miller when he finds out that
Monica and Chandler and then he comes
he's like come over I'll make You
fajitas and he's like freaking out why
he does Jack dammit submitted by Penn
State loves JK news yep Pennsylvania a
man is arrested for stealing 1.2 million
dollars who worth of fajitas in a scam
which lasted nine years oh can I tell
you something though fajitas are
delicious they are frozen fajitas too
you know the [ __ ] that you get out the
[ __ ] freezer and then you put that in
the baking sheet shit's [ __ ] behind
frozen fajitas that's what I'm sayin
though I like that ghetto [ __ ] did you
guys ever eat the get the fajitas from
McDonald's all the breakfast ones that's
chicken a bell pepper wrap in a tortilla
but she's delicious I don't like the he
knows everything I don't like same what
bell peppers and chicken and cheese no
it's the bell peppers and onions that's
what I don't think kinds of Mexicans are
you like bell peppers mm-hmm do for
gitis dude girl's vagina all right so
this man from Texas his name is Gilbert
Oh Lucy champ what oh I like that name
yeah so Gilberto Escamilla Escamilla
yeah better pop so this guy he he's an
employee at the Juvenile Justice
Department for the last nine years he
was ordering fajitas from the same
company that gives this Center mmm like
a lunch food yeah
and so he was he was ordering [ __ ] santo
fajitas and then this one day his whole
[ __ ] just got exposed because he went to
a doctor's appointment and while he was
gone the driver from this food service
delivery place they ended up calling to
verify an order that they were preparing
to deliver which was 800 pounds of
fajitas and then an employee at that
department they were just like Oh
no you have the wrong place like we
don't we don't even serve for Hughes at
this place oh so he's taking money from
the company
so he's been skimming fajitas yep and
then selling it on the fajita black
market because he was reselling it the
truth behind the fajitas fine present
fajitas present or the the place never
said like wait a minute we've never
served the heaters for anyone yeah they
did that's how come on it took them nine
years to realize I've never served if
maybe he's in control of the order yes
well every time that the food would come
in half you would be in charge of it but
I don't see it like no well you said
that we had fajitas but I've never seen
any of these students or whatever eating
up for you two ever well I mean if
you're the only food order and then
every time the delivery comes you're in
charge of it there's nobody to say that
you know what I heard I think I forget
what person tells you to do this but
they they tell you to send to have
mandatory vacations for people because
of [ __ ] like this so it's not to be nice
to employees but to check if they fail
and I'm pretty sure it to be nice to
them and to like to do that but it's
also form of check and balances because
then they get to see like if shits still
writing or if something just kind of
pops up we need to stop going on
vacations together that's right we all
go together and had no one staying at
home to check anything yeah so you could
check [ __ ] this dude was immediately
fired and then police went to his home
searched it and found a refrigerator
packed with fajitas oh no I think this
fajita Spanish stories were taking
heated by now it's pretty good it's very
smart though 1.2 million so they'd be
behind on and crazy they did an audit at
that at that place with it they were
delivering the he doesn't make included
that he stole 1 million two hundred and
fifty one thousand five hundred and
seventy eight dollars you'd almost a
crazy thing what if they like they got
him so where's the money first ain't no
money I just like
breakfast brunch [ __ ] knowledge
leaner dinner okay no nine years of just
that and where's this fajita black
market like is he in a dark corner and
likes you want chicken fajitas I think
she made the black market part up I made
them black market part of our lives in
the projects or something new cells the
people don't want cheap food yeah
because the police they were able to
uncover two of his purchasers who are
cooperating with the impact on the
fajita kingpins a hardened criminal
right here oh you fajita thief that's
right [ __ ] I [ __ ] self a heroes se
and this is the place where he was
feeling it from oh here's one for you to
tattoo right here wait that was a jail
right so you're just gonna go into the
place he was cooking for it's like a GB
hole yeah it do me huh yeah I gotta be I
gotta admire anyone who can make money
off with just the simplest things like
those guys that stole chicken for years
and made a ton of money I mean this is
pretty macchia behavior though like
people think mafias only do that but
what they do is they skim businesses a
lot they get people on the inside could
do things like this
did you hear about the guy that would
take a penny from like all the accounts
like he did program me he just took one
cent from everyone so you can't even
tell and then he made that and he he got
away I don't know Bob I say my
accounting accounting firm for like big
you just take a cent or something like
that the intruder they find him he never
did mm-hmm
he never found him oh how did they find
out I mean they found out what was going
on but they never they were never able
to track him down he's gone like that's
what I was how I want to live man just
like take money in the disappear off the
face book you don't want you're a good
guy no I'm not saying about I want to
hurt people because I sent this yeah I
just wanted to tell a penny from
everybody that's a dope slogan there's
300 million people in the US of A if you
took a penny from every single person's
just somebody do the math the best mean
dollar is pretty big now you we're
crossing the line with a dollar
penny is perfect yeah that could feed
people a penny cat is is a fagina a
American Mexican food or is that like a
text message the origins of fajitas what
kind of magic are you I don't
I feel like it was me like an Arizonan
yeah I feel like it's like text because
I only see that a chef actually food cuz
it's like this it's like stir-fry how
much money he was making per shipment Oh
apparently they do come from Mexico oh
it's making it go and United all right
well what's the way they make it in
Mexico's its stir-fry with bell peppers
to intestines and like cow feet so
fajitas are truly a tex-mex food thanks
man tex-mex Blanding Texas cowboy and
Mexican punch arrows food all questioned
breakfast sandwich or breakfast burrito
burrito
it really depends on my mood
with the Mexican coffee with the
cinnamon flavor you got me on a chicken
late chikhalia [ __ ] question then
croissant breakfast sandwich or
breakfast burrito what's in the
croissant sandwich it's a croissant from
pear Rima friend cuz if there's a zero
and cheese and it's like melted well
Austin I don't know the for the
breakfast croissant sandwich I'm talking
about soft scrambled eggs some cheddar
cheese and some crispy [ __ ] some
bacon in there my friend and then on the
side you've got a nice little salsa with
it real toe I'm with the burrito you
know like you know Taco Bell is still
actually kind of good and I like it a
lot much have you guys had their
breakfast my girl you know the
Crunchwrap supreme yeah I like the fact
that I don't indulge in this type of
[ __ ] junk food debauchery and I still
look like this I just I might as well
just eat it at this point
whoo [ __ ] that [ __ ] dude have you tried
walking a minute a day men walking
you know what I will say even used to
exercise that he lost like 20 pounds no
Joe you don't like you lost weight - oh
yeah that's amazing but Bart says it's
okay because it's hilarious
[Laughter]
it's funny it's hilarious and it's quite
clever so it makes me laugh but I cry
later how long did it take him to make
1.2 million nine years that's not a lot
it's still a hundred Jesus yeah though
man how are you being so picky when his
ass has $0
I can't map good okay wait Annie had a
job so that's urgent extra on a
government job government jobs pinku I
want to know how often are the drop-offs
and how much per shipment that's why I
won't know and that's like a hundred or
something geez straight on tatics it's
all white chicks for $2,000 oh yeah I
really think taxes are unfair the big
black guy in the back I don't want to
give the government any money anymore
I'm gonna change I'm gonna I'm Moodle
I'm moving to the Galapagos Tortoises
but the muta triangle is bro oh is it ya
know the Galapagos is near that one
Island Easter Island right so remember
what I said know nothing about this
world yeah gas is Pro and Bermuda
pajamas no cause I see toys no he did
hey we need to talk about the the real
issues here like what is your favorite
Mexican food but can be straight up like
this go if I have one mixing flatly for
the rest of life street tacos yeah three
tacos you know I'm saying or or it would
have to be like oh it's kind of hard to
say because I also really like that soup
albondigas cuz that's my life there you
that would like gets me my soul though
Bondi guys is kind of good delicious
sana is BOM did I wish you try why don't
you take us there why you only take
Pacey you can take guys up really I
don't know confusing Casey you threw me
out you can take tight guys to your your
your motherland me choices me choices
name your next kid if it's a boy Kaizen
just like the program that'd be dope
that sounds strongest [ __ ] what's up
guys how do we do did you like it did
you hate it well guess what there's only
a like button and if you liked it that's
the way to communicate that to us so
make sure to hit that like button and
for more episodes click right above me
[Music]